angela y le quiero dar concretamente los
datos de estos cuatro estados que pese
toda la atención está puesta sobre ellos
el primero de ellos nevada que ya tiene
un 92 por ciento de votos contados baile
en este momento tiene una ventaja de
20.000 votos a su favor esto
representaba pues una margen de un 16
por ciento es importante resaltar que en
eua de las 7 de la noche habrá una
actualización de los votos en el condado
de clark con condado sobre todo
demócrata que puede incluso pues ampliar
aún más la ventaja para bailén en el
caso de pensilvania con el 96 por ciento
de votos contados baiden tiene ya una
ventaja de 13 mil 700 votos estos datos
los dos obviamente y citando a la
agencia de prensa de noticias ap
associated press sobre la que me estoy
basando para dar estos datos a arizona
que tiene una actualización a las nueve
de la noche de los votos tiene ya un 96
por ciento contado y pues tiene a bailén
con una ventaja de 39 mil votos y
georgia por último con un 99 por ciento
de votos contados que tiene by the end
una ventaja en ese estado
y 1.600 votos sin embargo en georgia
pues ahora un reconteo
y cuáles son o han sido las reacciones
más recientes del presidente triunfé y
que se sabe sobre el discurso que dará
hoy el candidato demócrata joe biden
si el presidente de trump en su cuenta
de twitter pues sigue cuestionando estas
elecciones dice que con el ataque de la
izquierda al senado de eeuu es mucho más
importante ganar la presidencia y
quedarse cuatro años más lo que me ha
estado informando es que posiblemente el
presidente trump también a las 8 de la
noche haga un discurso a la misma hora
que el candidato demócrata joe biden
tenía planeado hacer su discurso desde
delaware algo que puede entonces hacer
que alguno de los dos candidatos pues
nueva un poquito el horario de su
discurso para no pues dar el discurso a
la misma hora
estas son entonces las reacciones hasta
ahora del presidente trump que sigue acá
en la casa blanca esperando esté
contento